[Música]
con su arquitectura su historia y su
excepcional patrimonio algunos pueblos
franceses son más que Lugares para vivir
son tesoros que hay que preservar en
córcega el pueblo de San Antonio ubicado
en la cima de una montaña es uno de
ellos construido en el siglo ix para
defender la zona de los moros Invasores
musulmanes procedentes de España San
Antonio nunca Fue capturado a Olivier
viáconi historiador y guía Corzo le
encanta mostrarle la ciudad a Los
visitantes
[Música]
estamos en la plaza dominante rodeada de
murallas defensivas
probablemente se trate de los restos de
las primeras murallas
hay una vista panorámica de 360 grados
del campo circundante
un pequeño paraíso con la etiqueta de
pueblo más bonito de Francia que algunos
No abandonarían por nada del mundo a sus
22 años Vincent Geraldine es el único
joven que queda en el pueblo ayudado por
su padre recoge aceitunas en la antigua
un trabajo duro en estas empinadas
laderas pero gracias a él esta tierra se
mantiene productiva
cuando quito las malas hierbas y limpio
durante semanas y la gente mayor dice
nunca lo había visto tan limpio y
ordenado me siento feliz pienso es viejo
y conoce este olivar desde hace años es
genial si me fuera otro sitio no Me
sentiría bien mi vida está aquí mucha
gente viene a visitar el pueblo por la
etiqueta es muy importante es el pueblo
más bonito de córcega sino de Francia al
otro lado de Francia en Bretaña los
habitantes de bonabén también están
orgullosos de su pueblo fue aquí donde
el pintor Paul gaudín eligió vivir y
fundar junto a otros artistas la célebre
escuela de ponna ven el acuarelista
Christian Ruiz también se ha enamorado
de los encantos del pueblo
A veces salgo en Barca por el río avena
y me siento allí solo en el lecho del
río con la marea baja
y alrededor hay garzas reales despegando
y aterrizando silencio total es
realmente algo especial
cada día es diferente aquí dependiendo
de la luz también tienes que elegir los
colores hoy tenemos grises azulados la
luz cambiante de Pon a Ben le ha valido
el calificativo de el desvío más bello
de Francia inspirando a generaciones de
pintores no estaba segura de dónde te
habías instalado se está muy bien aquí
Jacqueline la pareja de Cristian nació
aquí se ha codeado con artistas toda su
vida Cuando mi madre Me pedía que fuera
a comprar el pan bajado al pueblo y
podía haber exposiciones de pintura
gratuitas
mientras caminamos por el avenge
Jacqueline Nos invita a retroceder en el
tiempo hace dos siglos artistas
franceses estadounidenses y británicos
acudían a estas Riberas en busca de
inspiración solían alojarse en esta
posada
había buen ambiente se iban a pintar
todo el día y cuando volvían por la
tarde se reunían todos se dice que
colgaron sus cuadros en la pared nada
más volver a la posada lo más probable
es que los dejaran secar
luego miraban los cuadros de los demás
los evaluaban los discutían
se inspiró en estas casas para pintar la
banderas en ponnaban y fue en este
estudio donde pintó el bello ángel
en Bretaña siempre ha producido colores
dignos de obras de arte
[Música]
en la costa azul los sistos la banda
Aves del paraíso y sobre todo la mimosa
han dado renombre al pueblo de brandley
mimosa esta Perla de la región de bar es
reconocida como uno de los pueblos
florales más bonitos de Francia y es en
gran parte Gracias a la pasión de Albert
Draco
[Música]
fue el alcalde quien me pidió que
empezara a florecer el pueblo en 1964
quería crear una sensación de otro mundo
para Los visitantes de bourney
El jardinero del pueblo empezó a plantar
curiosidades de otras partes del mundo
como este hibisco chino eso fue en 1965
la exposición a la luz de borne nos
permite cultivar este tipo de flores
junto con el aire Marino además estamos
a 100 metros sobre el nivel del mar por
lo que el pueblo está a 5 grados más
fresco que abajo en 1970 el Consejo
Nacional de pueblos florales concedió a
born su etiqueta de cuatro flores y
desde entonces el pueblo nunca la ha
perdido para que su reinado continúe
born invierte cada año más de 100.000
euros y también convoca anualmente el
concurso el jardín más bonito Marie Rose
Ponce lo ha ganado dos veces quizás
porque dedica varias horas al cuidado
del jardín hay que regar
quitar las flores marchitas un jardín
bien cuidado visible desde el exterior
de la propiedad Esa es la exigencia de
los jueces que pueden pasar por allí
cualquier día sin avisar y sin ser
vistos y que parecen apreciar la
variedad de flores de Mario
caléndulas francesas por supuesto y
muchas petunias porque florecen muy bien
pero es caro al menos 500 euros
pero a Mario Rose no le importa el gasto
mientras su jardín esté lleno de flores
y mientras su querido pueblo de bornes
siga siendo uno de los más bellos de
Francia
[Música]